And now it's the old scout master.
So here we are at our campsite
And this guy comes riding through on a horse
And he stops and talks with us a little while
And, yeah, it's a beautiful horse,
But the horse does. you know what horses do?
The guy's getting ready to ride away.
I look at what the horse left there on the ground
And I say to the rider I said, hey, buddy,
are you going to leave that lion here?
And he looks at me and he says no, it's a horse
And I'm taking it with me.
I'm sorry.
Hey, this is podcast number 123..
Welcome back to the Scout Master podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, let's take a look at the mailbag here.
Well, we got a few messages about our last podcast,
which was a scout master panel discussion about parent issues,
And Peter LaRue wrote in and he said:
great show about dealing with parents.
It can be particularly tough for younger scouts.
There's some nice pointers there.
One tip I found helpful with difficult parents
is to ask them to get involved running things
that they're unhappy about.
This has one of two results:
They either backpedal and leave you alone
or get involved and often surprise you with their involvement.
True,
And Greg Sepley backs you up, Peter,
because Greg wrote in and said:
Peter has a great point.
What I usually do after they complain
or get vocal about something
is ask them what they would do in my place
And then, after they tell me what they would do,
I say: you're hired,
That's great.
This almost always is followed by them
taking the whole thing down a notch.
Thanks, Greg,
Nice little word of wisdom there.
Ann Olson wrote in again and said:
this show came in handy for us this week.
That's great to hear.
And we also heard from Derek Morton
who said really great stuff.
I'm amazed every week how relevant your podcasts are.
Thank you
Well, thank you for being in touch, Derek.
And Steve Mahoney wrote in.
He said: hey, Clark, I'm currently a Cub Scouter,
but I listened to your podcast
to understand the Scouting program better.
You're a big help.
Thanks very much.
Thanks very much, Steve.
I really appreciate you listening in.
So in this podcast
we're going back to podcast number 74..
Remember podcast number 74, how we all loved it.
Yes, I remember it well.
And we're going back to hear
an episode of Scout MasterChip
in seven minutes or less dealing with summer camp,
Because you know it's that time of year
started thinking about summer camp.
I got a great summer camp story to tell you,
And I have a couple of reflections
gleaned from an email question
that I received this week.
So that's enough for this podcast,
Wouldn't you say,
Because that's what I'm saying,
That's what I got for you.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout MasterChip in seven minutes
or less.
One of the most fun things I've gotten to do
in scouting was be on our camp staff,
And I was able to do that for about 12 years
as a director in different departments
and as a camp director,
And so the advice I'm about to give you
is kind of based on watching hundreds of different troops
and thousands of different scout leaders
over those 12 years come and experience
a week of summer camp.
There's some common difficulties and problems
that arise,
And there's some things that you can do
that will just make things go a lot better for you
while you're there at camp with your scouts,
And scout camp is a great place to go
if you're a scout.
It's fun,
There's lots of challenges,
There's great stuff to do,
And it's the same as when you're an adult.
It's just a little bit of a different level.
Now, if it's the first couple of times
you go to scout camp, it can be really stressful.
It can be. you know. you can be faced
with a lot of new things, a lot of things
that you're unfamiliar with.
You're not quite sure what the expectations are.
So you do have to take real good care of yourself.
Now that's if you've been going to camp,
you know if this year is your first time
or your 25th year going.
You have to take good care of yourself physically,
because if you take good care of yourself physically
you're going to be in good shape mentally
to handle camp.
Our camp is one of the only remaining ones
that has a seven day schedule.
We bring everybody in on Sunday
and they leave on the following Sunday,
So somebody gets to camp.
You know your average adult leader gets to camp
on a Sunday afternoon
And yeah, first day of camp.
that's kind of stressful.
There's a lot of things to do,
There's new things to learn,
There's people to meet, places to get to,
And you might feel a little bit rushed
and by the time you're headed off to bed that night
you're probably pretty tired
and you may sleep well and you may not.
And you know the food's going to be a little different,
The water's going to be a little different.
Your latrine's going to be a little different.
You're going to have a lot of the same experiences
that the boys do with unfamiliar stressors
and things like that.
But you're also going to be older than they are.
I don't know if you notice that.
So you know your abilities are going to be compromised
maybe by being a bit older than they are,
being a little more set in your ways,
and you could become cranky real fast.
And how do I know this?
Do I have to tell you?
I mean, I've been there,
I've done it,
I've not taken very good care of myself physically
and then I get real cranky
and yeah, then things just get ugly.
So if you are hot, tired, hungry, thirsty,
you need to get cool, you need to get rested,
you need to get fed and you need to get hydrated.
And that's going to be a pretty big service
to you yourself personally,
your fellow leaders, your troop and the camp staff.
If you're not cranky and mean,
it's going to make the whole week go a lot easier.
So that's one key piece of advice.
You're coming into a situation
that you may not be familiar with,
but you've got a staff there,
people who are adults
and who've been at it for a long time.
and then you've got young adults,
guys who are around college age,
who've got a lot of energy
and may have been at the camp staff job
for several years.
and then you've got a bunch of younger staff members
who are basically learning right along with your scouts.
They're learning a lot of things
right along with your scouts.
Now they probably are a little bit farther ahead of them
as far as the camp things go,
but maturity-wise and things like that,
they're going to be more like
your average 15,, 16,, 17-year-old
And you've got to take that into account.
You need to be considerate and supportive of them
in the same way that you're considerate
and supportive of your scouts.
You never, ever want to step in
and be raid or criticize or argue
with a camp staff member.
You don't want to do that with a youth leader
in your troop.
You don't want to do that with a fellow adult leader
and you certainly don't want to do that
in the presence of scouts.
And now model how much you may think
that that staff member deserves it.
What you want to do is you want to have
either a quiet talk with them or their boss,
at an appropriate distance from the scouts
and that will usually solve the problem,
And sometimes that might be your problem.
You have to realize that camp staff members
are totally dedicated to making your stay worthwhile
and your idea of what might be right
and their idea of what might be right
could be two different things.
So you kind of got to go with the flow a little bit.
You got to join in the program
and encourage your scouts to do so,
even if the program, in your humble opinion,
isn't all that great.
If you go to a scout camp
and you eat in a dining hall,
there's usually a program around the dining hall time
and you know it may be
a really great whizbang, high energy program
and it might not be all that great.
but what really encourages a lackluster
kind of difficult program is a lively audience.
A lively audience goes a long, long way
and you and your troop, with the right attitude,
could be the catalyst that makes for a great week
for everybody in camp.
You know, in the vast scheme of things
I know that as a staff member
and as a directory camp
we always emphasize that we were serving scouts
and scout leaders
and we were doing our dangest
to make them comfortable
and to make things work well for them.
Now, that's being said,
You don't want to go pulling rank
as an adult or a scout leader.
You don't want to ask for special privileges.
You don't want to try and impress the staff members
with your self-importance.
A lot of people instantly respect
your position as a scout leader
and they're going to try
and do their best for you.
Just don't make a big giant deal out of it.
There's really no rank to be pulled there
and remember that these guys are working hard
trying to help you,
So just go easy.
You need to look for the opportunities
to participate with a lot of gusto
and a lot of spirit in ceremonies
and traditions and practices of the camp,
even if they're unfamiliar to you.
If it's the first time you end up at a scout camp,
and maybe it's a new one that you're trying out
with your troop, get into it,
Jump right in.
Camps and camp staff members
are very proud of their traditions
and you don't want to try to impose
the way that everybody did it
at the last camp you were at
or the way that you think it should be done.
Let them call the shots,
Let them run the show and just jump in
and have a great time with it.
You'll be a camp with a lot of different scout troops
who will be run one way,
but you might be doing things a different way
and sometimes little inner troop rivalries
may develop.
Now, scout age boys, as you know,
they're pretty hyper competitive
and they need to be reminded about
fairness and courtesy and sportsmanship
every once in a while.
So you want to set the tone,
when there's competition, of it
being a gentlemanly, scout-like competition,
and you want to make sure that you require that
of your scouts.
As always, with anything we do,
give our youth leaders all the responsibility
for success,
See that they understand what needs to be done,
how and why, and then observe them
from a respectful distance,
Check in with them every evening,
ask lots of questions and
put your ore in when you're asked for it
where it's a matter of safety,
but otherwise, let them run their troop,
let them work with the camp program
and the camp staff to do that.
You know you can run a lot of interference
by learning what happens next for them
or if you have the experience
that you can share with them.
You know, be proud of your scouts,
Encourage them and congratulate them, admire them,
but let them have all the responsibility
and all the credit for
the success of their troop.
This has to be the truth, folks,
because there is no way
way
anyone could make this up.
So this story happened in 1993-
wow, almost 20 years ago,
can you believe it?
I was working at our camp
and I was serving, I'm pretty sure, that year.
I was the camp commissioner
and so I was down there for the whole summer
and we had
just a fantastic staff at camp,
and amongst the staff was
Mr Peter J Mendez,
a force of nature.
He was a program director
and Pete's
been one of my favorite people
in scouting
for a very long time
and we've kept up
correspondence and friendship.
I was in his wedding a year or two ago
and
but Pete and I
somehow,
in that kind of magic alchemy
that is a summer at camp,
latched on
to this song
from
wait for it now,
Ran and Stimpy.
Do you remember Ran and Stimpy?
Yeah, a questionable cartoon.
we were big fans.
and so there was this song
and it was about
a fictitious product
called LOG.
It's on your back,
It's long, long, long.
It's long, long.
It's heavy, it's wood,
It's better than that, it's good.
So Pete and I somehow got in the habit
of, during meals
in the dining hall,
singing the LOG song
and a lot of the scouts-
well, they were Ran and Stimpy fans too-
and so they caught on pretty quickly
and this began to snowball on us.
it started to snowball on us
and I remember one meal-
I think it was
Pete and I- found LOGs
and we brought them into the dining hall
and we presented them as our pet LOGs
and we encouraged the scouts
to go and adopt a LOG,
because you know
it's a scout-like thing to do.
and so at the next meal
a bunch of the scouts had
LOG with them
and they introduced their
pet friend, the LOG.
and then we talked about
the different rules for having a LOG.
for instance,
you needed to keep your LOG
on a leash- that was a rule around camp-
and the leash needed to be
applied to the LOG with nothing other than a timber hitch,
because otherwise you might injure the LOG.
so imagine this:
now you're walking around camp one day
and you- not every single scout,
but a good many of them-
have a LOG
at the end of a rope,
dragging it around
between their
different Maribad sessions.
then we hit on the idea that
we needed to issue LOG tags,
you know, like dog tags,
but you needed a license
to have a LOG at camp.
so we quick put together a little form
and everything like that and threw it on the photocopier
and we photocopied out LOG registration forms
and you could come up to the headquarters building
and you could register your LOG
at the headquarters building for the
sum of ten cents
and we give you a tag
that you could staple to your LOG.
and that way when we were out and around
and we found somebody running around with a LOG
on a rope, we checked their registrations
and
so you know,
every single meal there would be something
about the LOG.
and as the week grew,
people were
variously amused and aggravated
by the
entire development
and
and I remember
that the whole thing kind of culminated
in
a couple of the other guys on staff
getting a LOG that way I think was maybe about
10 or 12 feet long-
and bringing it into the dining hall.
and
it was a very memorable event,
very memorable summer. now we have the habit of putting
plaques up
around the dining hall.
you know, a troop can make one
and there's always one that the staff makes
and it goes up
and it's still there
in our dining hall
with- I think I got to be
stimpy and Pete
got to be Wren-
painted on this plaque along with
LOG, and so
the memory of that summer
is memorialized
for future generations to puzzle over.
LOG,
LOG.
write me a letter,
send it by name
email. that is, folks.
and here's an answer to one
of your emails.
well, here's a
recent email exchange I had.
I'm withholding the name
and location of the person who sent me the email
and you'll see why,
but it's kind
of typical of emails
I get from time to time
and a parent emails me
asking my advice and resolving a conflict
they have with a scout master.
this is the situation
that was described to me.
my son had one requirement
left to do for first class,
the compass and orientation hike.
I notified the scout master
that my son would miss the troop meeting
where they were doing this requirement,
and he emailed me back stating
he would work with my son
to get the course completed at the next meeting.
in our troop,
the scout master is the only one
that signs off requirements.
on rare occasions an assistant scout master
will sign them off.
we did get to the next meeting
and my son did get a few of his requirements
that he had already completed
signed off and that was kind of like pulling teeth.
at the end of the meeting the scout master
told me and my son that
even though they didn't get the course done that night,
that if he came the next week
he would get the course done
and have the scout master conference and border review
and then become a first class scout.
then I got an email
from the scout master in the ensuing week
that said there would be too much going on
at the meeting and he wouldn't have time
to work with my son at that meeting.
all they did was play games.
nobody helped my son. there was plenty of time
and I even contacted the committee chair
but he never responded.
I even had a friend step up
and talk to the committee chair
and he said that my son
just can't complete the compass course.
now, after two promises to my son
to get this taken care of,
I'm disappointed in this troop.
this is not the scouting way.
nowhere do I read in the handbook
that the course has to be done with a group
and technically none of the boys
have really earned the requirement,
because it turns out the course that they did
was not as the requirement described.
I do have a friend whose son is in the troop too,
and he and his wife went out of their way
to set up an official
compass oriented course last night
with my son.
they're going to try their best to get the situation resolved
but as of now the committee chair
is not returning phone calls
and I just wanted to know
what you think would be the next steps
and, as I said, I'm withholding
the name
and the location for obvious reasons.
now I know how upsetting this sort of thing is
and how frustrating it can all be,
and I'm going to challenge a couple of things
that this parent is doing
and I wanted to come
across with all the kindness and empathy
with which it is intended.
there are a couple of basic
missteps being made
that have kind of snowballed into
this situation
and I think basically
it comes down to three major issues to discuss.
the description of the troop
program that I gleaned
from this email
sounds like more of an extension of Weeblows
than it does. Boy Scouts,
the scout master signing all the requirements
to complete them
when and where he sees fit.
there is no reason
that a scout couldn't complete this
first class requirement on his own
or with a buddy outside of a troop meeting or event.
I know that if he came to me
with his handbook
and he described how he accomplished
the requirement,
I'd ask him some questions maybe
and I'd sign it off.
but more likely than not,
my youth leaders would do that:
sign many handbooks.
the second problem: I see,
and I think I understand
why it's happened,
but I have to wonder why this parent is so involved
in this.
I mean, why aren't they, instead of their son,
dealing with the scout master
and making these arrangements?
again, we're in Weeblows territory,
not Boy Scout territory.
I would-
and I say this as kindly and
understandingly as possible- encourage
them to allow
the boy, allow that
scout, the autonomy to make these decisions
and plans for himself.
he'll certainly learn and grow
a great deal more if he does.
and number three:
what's the source of the conflict here?
what's the problem?
well, because this particular scout master
has reserved all authority to himself
and is not-
and this is my opinion, based only on
what this parent has told me-
the scout program functioned properly
and that causes
parents to become defensive
and over involved,
and they get over
involved in charting their son's ways forward
and then inevitably
this is going to turn into a conflict somewhere.
now, if you listen to the last
podcast and the scout master panel
discussion we had about parent issues,
if you're following the program,
the program stands on its own and defends itself.
if you're not following
the program- like as I said
in my judgment based on this email,
this particular scout master
not following the program-
then you're opening yourself
up to these kind of arguments and difficulties.
some parents
are going to be over involved
and you have to kind of explain the
program to them and ask them to step back
a little bit and see if you can get
them to work with that, and in
99% of the instances you're
going to. so my final
advice to this parent is:
stop arguing.
don't stop arguing
with the scout master. stop bothering the
committee chair about this. this is
snowballed into this kind of conflict
because nobody's right,
because
they're not following
the scout program.
okay, I. why
are they doing requirements
at a troop meeting? now everybody's
going to say, Clark, everybody does
requirements at a troop meeting. well,
yeah, kind of maybe, but
we're not in business
to do requirements.
we do the things that scouts do
and that just happens to be requirements.
parent mentioned in the email
an official orienteering course
with the compass and everything like that.
there's no such thing.
there is an orienteering course that the
requirement describes,
and you just do that in the course of a
thing, or maybe you do it at a troop meeting
or something like that. but why are you doing it?
not, though, so that scouts can
fulfill requirements, but so that scouts
can do the things that scouts
do.
that's how they advance in scouting:
not by fulfilling requirements,
but by doing the things that
scouts do. now, if you
find yourself toe to toe
with the way that a troop is operating,
you have two basic options:
you stay with the current troop
and accept that you don't like the way that
they do things, or you find another troop
that better suits your idea of scouting.
to me, that decision
is always up to the scout.
now, recently,
I had a boy in my troop
who was getting discouraged with scouting
and really didn't enjoy it anymore because
the friends that had crossed over
with him from weevilos
and who had joined their troop
had left.
they decided that they weren't interested
in scouting anymore and they quit scouts,
and he was the only one left,
and his father was quite involved in everything like that
and dad came to us
and he said: you know, this is a real problem
for me because I want to continue on.
I was an eagle scout. I'd love my son to be an eagle scout,
but he's just not interested in this anymore
because none of his friends are there.
and that's the only reason
that a boy- you know, when a boy is 11
or 12 or years old,
he gets the idea that
scouting is fun,
perhaps that he's building his character
and stuff like that.
but what's his motive for being involved?
his friends are involved.
he had a buddy in school who was involved with this other troop
and so I told dad
I said: well, what about the other troop?
does he have any friends that are involved there?
and they went and visited that find out that he has friends.
so they moved to the other troop.
no problem, no problem,
the boys still in scouts.
dad will be able to be involved with him,
even though dad would rather
stay with our troop because
dad likes the way that we do things.
so if you're going to make a decision about this,
it starts with the scout.
listen, you're in the troop with your friends.
I'm having a little problem
seeing that my way forward.
I don't think that they're doing things quite the way
that I envision them.
do you want to stay there with your friends,
or shall we look for another troop?
maybe the answer is going to come back
and you don't like the answer, which is
no, I want to stay with my friends.
even in a troop that's not
strictly applying the scouting program,
boys get a good experience.
boys are still going to have a fine
experience out of it.
we're talking about, sometimes,
degrees of things here, aren't we?
so let's just go back over this again.
there are three problems here.
obviously, this
troop, in my opinion,
based on the email that I read,
is not following the scout program
in the optimal way that it should happen.
this causes conflict
and
the conflict is kind of irresolvable
because they're not following the program.
and because they're not following the program,
a parent is getting over
involved
and that causes conflict too
and it's kind of irresolvable
why we're not following the program.
so the options
basically come down to this:
you stick with this troop
where, if you just can't see your way through,
you find something that better suits
your idea of scouting.
you're not going to change this troop
and, forgive me,
I've probably said this
any number of times on the blog and the podcast,
but I'm going to repeat it again:
for a parent
to get in
and to try and change
the way that a troop operates-
especially if it's a troop of long standing
and they have a certain way of operating-
is pretty much a fool's errand.
most of the time
some people make it work,
but it's because they are very patient
and they work very carefully
and they go forward
very incrementally.
the people with authority
within the organizational structure of scouting
are the chartered organization represented,
the troop committee chairman
and the head of the chartered organization.
if they're not interested in making changes,
no changes are going to be made,
and so you're just going to be creating
a lot of heat and very little light.
so
my advice to people is usually:
look, you don't really jibe
with the way that they're doing things.
find another place where it works better for you.
or if your son
really wants to stay here because his friends are here,
then you're just going to live with it,
because this is not an experience for you,
this is an experience for your son.
and once again,
what is it all about?
what's this whole thing that we're involved in all about?
it's focused on the boy.
it's to give him certain experiences
and challenges and opportunities.
he gets to do that with a group of his friends
and we get to have what Baden Powell
called the jollity of scouting.
it's a fun time-
it should be a great time- where we grow
and we learn together.
when conflicts come up, we can certainly resolve them,
and when we're running the scouting program,
when we're doing what the program says,
we not only avoid conflicts,
but when they inevitably arise-
and they will-
we have a way to resolve them.
so I hope that helps everybody.
if you're in the middle of a similar situation
or if you have a question that you'd like to hear answered on the podcast,
you can get in touch with me
and you'll find out how to do that in just a moment.
well, thanks for listening to this edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you get in touch:
read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom
and there you can subscribe to receive
updates to the blog
by email.
you can also subscribe to the scoutmaster podcast
on iTunes and when you do,
feel free to leave a comment
or review or a rating.
you can also access the podcast
on your mobile device
through Stitcher Smart Radio
and you get details about how to do that
at stitchercom.
would you like to leave a shout out for somebody,
for your troop or for a fellow scouter,
on a future podcast?
well, go to scoutmastercgcom
to find out how to call in
and record a shout out
for inclusion in a future podcast.
you can experience all the wonders
of scoutmastercgcom
through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
at Facebook,
follow us at scoutmaster blog,
tweet us at scoutmastercg on twitter
and, for admittance to the exclusive
scoutmastercg circle,
search for scoutmastercg
on google plus.
please email me, Clark Green,
with your comments and questions
and wild ideas at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
the scoutmaster blog
and the scoutmaster podcast are not official
publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed or sponsored
by the Boy Scouts of America.
with a microphone trying to help out fellow
scouters and maybe have a little bit of fun along the way.
speaking of fun, before we leave you
let's hear from our founder,
Sir Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you
and good camping.
Well, thank you, sir. until next time, everybody
you.